welcome back let's talk do's and don'ts
for becoming a homeowner Rocky spoke
with Clark County Credit Union the
sponsors of this segment to get their
tips
now you know obviously getting a home
buying a home is an exciting time but it
can be a little scary for some people so
where should they start let's just start
there the best place to start would be
to speak to your loan officer
um they're going to have kind of the
best idea of the programs and guidelines
and look over your situation to kind of
set you on the path but just in general
savings is a good point you're going to
need some funds one way or the other you
know for down payment closing costs
um your earnest money deposit even after
closing you might be furniture that you
want to buy or appliances repairs or
Renovations so it's good to start
setting aside that money in advance we
have a program exclusive to Clark County
Credit Union we call it the home now it
allows for two percent down on a
conventional loan uh which is pretty
stellar because most conventional loans
require at least three percent down and
that's if you're a first on home buyer
uh if you're not a first-time home buyer
they want five percent down so two
percent is a significant savings and you
can use those extra funds to kind of
help you with those other items you
might need oh so much to consider so
much to learn
um right right anything else that you
guys uh would tell people to start
preparing for as they as they enter this
process definitely I mean you you
definitely want to you know review your
credit credit scores and important part
of uh you know getting approved to buy a
home so you know and remember for a
mortgage loan we require all three
bureaus uh for the credit report not
just one so make sure you're looking at
all that keep you know your payments all
on time make sure that the uh the bet
you know the limit on your credit cards
is it more than like 50 of the balance
you know or I'm sorry fifty percent of
the limit is what I meant to say and
then the other thing is also watch out
for big car payments that can be a major
hurdle like if you're in the market for
a home in a car get the home first
because the dealership will find a way
to get you in the car you know a
mortgage underwriter will say no
that's really good advice that is a
great reminder now if everyone has you
know these things lined up and
everything is in place because they've
been working with you guys um you know
what type of mortgage should they sign
up for their office yeah I mean there
are all sorts of mortgage options and it
can be overwhelming to you know the
first time home buyer even someone who's
had a home before
and they all kind of sound the same you
know Freddie Mac FHA VA you know there's
no way so you want to talk to like one
of the experienced loan officers here at
Clark County Credit Union they'll review
your situation and kind of set you up
with the program that best meets your
goals
as we're you know thinking about buying
a home or ready to buy our first home
what is the first step
I I'd say you know give uh you know
Clark County Credit Union a call or you
can go online uh to
ccculv.org on there you can review all
the mortgage products we offer we have
all sorts we even have uh you know land
and construction loans if you want to
build your own home plus that two
percent down option so it's a good
program so whatever your you know your
dream home goals are we can help you get
there
thank you to Clark County Credit Union
for more information you can call
702-228-2228 or visit
ccculv.com and they have a special offer
cccu home now program offers a two
percent down payment for qualified
buyers